the Giants have a game coming up on
Sunday against a team that played last
Thursday the Buccaneers beat the
Panthers they welcome the Giants to town
and the Giants will be putting out on
the field quarterback Daniel Jones as
the starter for the first time Eli
Manning gets benched for the second time
in his career the last time it didn't
take this time it's probably going to
take and various individuals central to
this storyline met with the media on
Wednesday let's begin with Pat Shermer
he was asked by reporters why did you
make the change now here's what he said
I think it just was my gut that it was
time to make that move I think when you
draft a guy like you know when you draft
a guy like we did at some point and that
was part you know that was part of my
conversation at some point this was
going to happen and I just felt like
this was the time go with the guy and I
understand that the gut feeling is
influenced by a variety of factors that
only he is privy to and he's in the
building every day and he's seeing
what's happening on the practice field
etcetera but I if his gut was telling
him to go with Daniel Jones now Chris
his gut was telling him to go with
Daniel Jones two weeks ago he just
wasn't able to convince the people above
him in the organization to do it that's
my tank oh my god with you there you
know I think that this is a move that
you know for it to be made how to be
okay okay by the mayor of family I would
imagine that that's the case and I would
think that you know even if Pat Shermer
did want to start Daniel Jones
week one and felt like it gave him the
best chance that that probably was not
allowed to happen because Eli was good
enough in training camp and preseason to
justify one more shot at it but I still
will go back and not only to what
everybody saw in the field from Eli
Manning and week one and week two I
think the fact that we saw that fan
reaction and Bouldin the brass of the
Giants to finally say okay I think the
fans have you know swallowed the reality
that Eli Manning is no longer the guy he
once was and they're a little excited to
see this Daniel jones guy because he did
look amazing in the preseason he was
probably won the award for best rookie
quarterback in the preseason right so I
think ultimately you're right it was not
more about schirmer's gut but the
family and how they wanted this all to
be handled so schirmer's ready for
Daniel Jones would be the starter the
fans are ready for Daniel Jones to be
the starter is Daniel Jones
ready to be the starter he was asked
that question yesterday here's what he
had to say in response I certainly feel
feel good about you know how far I've
come you know in my preparation and my
progress since you know since I got here
in the spring and you know through camp
through these first couple weeks so you
know what you will you know try to make
sure we have the best week we can and
you know I'll certainly do all I can to
be as as prepared as possible but yeah I
think you know I feel ready and you know
certainly looking forward to opportunity
I bet that dudes a blast at parties
my goodness talk about sucking the
energy out of the room but that's what
they wanted right Chris that's right a
guy who's gonna be flatline yes they
want a guy who's not gonna be affected
by anything right they want a guy who's
gonna go out there and get the job done
and not choked in the clutch like Kirk
Cousins does that's what they have
that's what they've got it's not gonna
be a bunch of great great press
conferences from Daniel Jones but they
want a guy who's gonna go out there just
be kind of like a stone-cold killer when
it's time to to carve up a defense with
his arm no question I mean yeah they
want a Flatliner a guy that's not gonna
be worried about what it says about him
on Broadway or Times Square when he
plays good or bad and that's the great
thing about what Eli Manning brought to
it and I've you know I've said this
before if my dad was the same way most
boring dammm interview you could ever
imagine when he was the quarterback of
the Giants that you know it's it's it's
almost like you know New England me in
that way as far as you know they just
don't want the quarterback to say a
whole lot of the players to say a whole
lot or either way but I'll say this much
okay on the field
Daniel Jones and again he's got to get
his feet underneath them and get used to
football in the NFL but I do think he's
gonna give them a better chance to win
football games and move the ball on the
offensive side of the ball as compared
to Eli Manning his arm just has more pop
in it he's gonna be more willing to
stand in the pocket and wait for plays
to develop and take shots to make big
throws down the field and the other
thing Mike is he's really
underappreciated athlete he can run and
if he gets a little lane don't be
shocked if he rips off a 15 and 20 yard
gain I mean he did that at Duke and I
think that's the thing that the Giants
are probably excited about that he can
bring to the offense yeah and and look
this is why they made into sixth overall
pick and you can say well we'd like to
do the Kasey model remember all that
talk remember all that yes yeah okay
model maybe even the Green Bay model
with Eli Manning really plays well and I
said how about the NY G model where you
bench your starter during the season and
I actually accelerated the timetable
because at least Kurt Warner got nine
games before he was benched for Eli
Manning in 2004 Eli got to and Eli got a
chance to talk to the media
on Wednesday about the change in his
circumstance here's what he'll I Manning
had to say no not to be positive about a
lot to be grateful for and you know and
and so I just got a you know kind of
accept my new role and make the best I'm
you know just taking this day by day so
just trying to figure out how to how to
run a scout team that was my number one
number one objective of today and does
it pretty well there's no way that he
believes what he's saying there's no way
he's not upset deep down that this
happened his job was taken away from him
just like they did two years ago right
and if he's got any competitive bone in
his body he is ticked off about what has
transpired and he's just saying the
right things and just that kind of
sarcastic yeah I'm just trying to figure
out how to run the scout team I mean
there's got to be a fire burning in
there somewhere and that fire has got to
be turned up to extra high after what
just happened to eli man i'm sure i mean
he's a competitor we know that i mean
he's an all-time competitor for for
football in the new york giants and he's
been awesome he's been an amazing team
guy he's never made a spectacle of
anything or said the wrong thing he's
just he's handled himself like the
ultimate professional his whole career
and he will continue to do that as he
backs up Daniel Jones I'm sure Mike yeah
he's pissed off and whatever else but I
do think Eli is logical enough to
believe the other things he said I got a
lot of things to be grateful for and I
think you know in the big picture of
things he can look at things ago man my
career was pretty damn good you know he
could just all he has to do was think
about his dad's career and go damn I was
pretty fortunate to be on a good team
and went to Super Bowls at least I
didn't get you know the short straw that
my dad got going in the New Orleans
Saints and just getting obliterated four
years so as tough as it is to swallow
and I can still remember the day my debt
my dad was told he was no longer the
Giants quarterback it's a sad day it
really is and I feel free live Manning
but he did have a great run and he was
phenomenal and he will be an NFL legend
in the history books isn't the best
outcome for everyone though a parting of
the ways no doesn't it doesn't it no
salt into the wound to have him standing
there in uniform on the sidelines every
week does I how is that good for anybody
Chris who does it help who doesn't
really help well III don't think Eli
Manning just wants to like okay pack up
the bags and go sit at home and sit on
the couch on Sundays I think he wants to
be there and and and probably enjoy what
will probably be his last season to a
degree you can take it all in from that
aspect Eli Manning doesn't want to be
anything but a New York giant and there
is something special to that you know
again I've gotten to see that I know my
dad holds that dearly to his heart as
far as being in New York giant for a 15
year career and I think Eli Manning's
the same way and he's certainly not
gonna uproot his family and kids and all
that and I think go somewhere else at
this point too so they're they're gonna
pay homage to him as the season goes
along and they're gonna send him off and
as a part of the positive way as they
possibly can and now you are walking
right into my next point because
remember we went into the season
believing that the Giants were going to
play Eli Manning for as long as they had
a mathematical opportunity to make it to
the postseason and then it would be
Daniel Jones down the stretch by making
the change now Chris I can tell you
what's gonna happen they have a late by
they've got a Monday night home game in
Novi
against the Cowboys they have in a way
game against the Jets in their home
stadium week 10 week 11 by during their
bye we're gonna start hearing clamoring
for an Eli
mini farewell tour three home games in
December there's going to be pressure on
the Giants to have him play week 17
against the Eagles week 15 against the
Dolphins maybe even week 13 against the
Packers and that's something that the
Giants don't need at a time when they're
trying to get reps for Daniel Jones
there will be a ton of pressure on this
team to let Eli Manning exit while he's
on the field not on the sidelines
another reason if you're gonna go with
Daniel Jones you'll rip the band-aid all
the way off you don't let it dangle
there you know how a band-aid dangles
when you ripped off half of it and
everything to letting the other half
just hang there until you can muster the
nerve to just kind of try to that's what
the Giants are gonna have a dangling
band-aid all year long until they rip it
off for good and I'm sorry do teams do
this all the time to players of every
shape and size and every number of years
of tenure with a team when it's done
it's done and for Eli Manning it's done
and they're doing him a disservice and
themselves a disservice and Daniel Jones
a disservice by having him hang around
and I don't mean that disrespectful at
all to Eli Manning on what he did but
now that it's over for God's sake just
end it well they're not gonna end it I
mean because they don't want to should
why if Daniel diss Vijayan still want to
win games pastures and then go on his
gravestone what his record is I mean if
he plays if they play horrible this year
he's gonna be on the hot seat does he
like Manny help your win game because if
Daniel Jones gets hurt then you have a
good backup that can come in that's how
and he is gonna help out Daniel Jones
with meetings and things to look for
he's not a jerk he's completely capable
of being that type of human being you're
crazy for that okay maybe they made a
mistake by letting them hang around it's
a different set of circumstances than
just a normal fire this is guys gonna go
to the Hall of Fame and won two Super
Bowls and two MVPs and now we can rattle
off his resume all day that's not the
point the point is going forward going
forward he's on the bench okay I think
it hurts hey let me let me ask you this
yes ask me it alright if this decision
gets made two weeks ago the Daniel Jones
is gonna be the week one starter and Eli
Manning is looking at that 11.5 million
dollar salary that becomes fully
guaranteed if he's on the roster week
one under the CBA's termination pay
provision but you can walk away from the
11.5 million that's a hell of a lot of
money to pay for a backup quarterback do
you cut him before week one if you
decide to commit to Daniel Jones as of
the first week of his rookie year no I
don't think they guess that yes you do I
don't think yeah yeah I mean they're not
I mean you know again it's a nice theory
but that's just not the reality okay
either way because they screwed up Oh
made the decision two weeks ago man they
should have moved on from Eli Manning
then no they would they would they're
not gonna trust any of the other guys
they have as a backup quarterback either
they're not gonna disrespect Eli Manning
and if Daniel Jones can't stand that Eli
Manning's on the sideline and they might
put a video tribute to him at some point
during week 17 and oh no he might have
to play series early 1700s art the game
who gives a damn who gives a damn it's
not gonna be like oh gosh Daniel Jones
his his his life and career over he lost
seven reps in the game he'll never be
the same look if you're I look you're
either all in or you're not and if
you're starting Daniel Jones you need to
be all in with him and the only way to
be all in with Daniel Jones is to get
Eli go to commercial you're wrong we got
to go to commercial
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports